you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme boris johnson says further
measures could be taken to help cut
energy costs as the government faces
calls to suspend green taxes on
electricity going green or green washing
the eu faces criticism over plans to
class both natural gas and nuclear power
as sustainable fuels
and air quality improves in china's
capital beijing but there's a long way
to go until the city meets international
guidelines on pollution
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
now boris johnson says he isn't ruling
out further measures to help address
rising energy costs the prime minister
has been urged to tackle rapidly rising
energy prices to avoid people having to
choose between eating or heating their
homes
some analysis suggests that bills could
go up by as much as 50 percent this year
and several suppliers have said a
short-term solution would be to suspend
green taxes when i speak to our business
correspondent paul kelso now so paul
just how much pressure is the government
under to cut the green taxes on our
energy bills
well it's significant pressure the
entire issue of energy bills because a
new year's present we can all look
forward to is a really significant
increase in the cost of heating and
lighting and powering our homes off gem
the regulator is currently considering
what price it will set the energy price
cap at beginning on april the first
we'll learn that next month most
analysts uh pre and the energy industry
predicting an at least 50 percent
increase in the lowest price will be
able to uh
set up and that could raise the average
bill to 2000 pounds for every household
up at least 50 percent in total that
would put nearly two percent on
inflation in the uk so it's a huge issue
it affects everyone and there is
pressure on the prime minister from two
sources to address uh the so-called
green taxes that are on energy bills
they're coming from his back benches
from those who supported the brexit
campaign in particular who have some
great sway in the conservative party at
the moment they would like to see they
have concerns about the whole cost of
net zero to consumers so there's an
opportunity they see here to push that
again but it's also coming from the
energy industry itself which has never
liked the idea that some of the costs of
moving to net zero should be added to
the bills that they charge their
customers but there is pushback not
least from the prime minister's official
spokesman today who played down the
prospects of those costs uh being
removed and sources i'm talking to point
out it isn't just the cost of the net
zero transition and green issues green
taxes that's in those uh in those
additional charges some of it are the
social costs funding the uh various
measures the government has to help
alleviate energy costs to those on low
incomes to the elderly and so on so
there's pressure there far bigger
pressure around vat and perhaps the
energy industry would like some loans
from government to offset these huge gas
price spikes whatever they choose the
government doesn't have very long to
make a decision and however much they
choose to cut our bills by if they do
take
that step we will all feel the impact of
that decision paul thanks very much
indeed
and we'll be discussing this in our
daily climate show debate a little bit
later in the programme today i'll be
joined by economist vicky price and
climate columnist for the independent
donica mccarthy
now controversial plans from the
european union have been revealed which
would allow natural gas and nuclear
power to be labeled as green investments
the proposal could potentially channel
billions of euros into the construction
of new power plants but the issue is
dividing eu member states now some
countries including france the czech
republic and poland believe that
carbon-free nuclear power is critical to
fight global warming and to help towards
a green transition
france for example gets around 71
percent of its electricity from nuclear
power
but germany and other countries consider
nuclear power to be dangerous germany
itself decided to close all its nuclear
power stations after the fukushima
incident in japan
the country is on track to phase out
nuclear power completely by the end of
this year
reliant on coal for 28 of its power
germany wants natural gas to be
recognized as a less polluting
transition fuel crucial for bringing
down emissions
well our euro correspondent adam parsons
is in brussels for us this evening so
adam just how controversial are these eu
plans proving to be then
oh hugely so because when you look
across the whole of the european union
everybody has something to say about
energy as you've been hearing the cost
of it is spiraling here in europe just
as much it is
in the united kingdom it is of course
crucial to life but also the european
union has got this pathway towards net
zero by 2050 and it's really bridled
against this idea of
green washing so what it came up with
was a horrible word taxonomy but really
it says categorizing energy investments
so that investors know what they're
doing so they can go for the most green
options the trouble is one person's
green it doesn't necessarily tally what
another ones and of course as you just
laid out there right at the heart of
this is this schism between the two big
players in european politics for the
french who really embrace nuclear power
and the germans who are throwing their
nuclear stations uh out of the window
they're going to be all done by the end
of this year to such extent they've
actually still had to use coal power
they rely a lot on gas guess what
they've got a pipeline that called
nordstrom 2 which is just about to open
that comes in from russia so you can
throw geopolitics into this as well
and this comes down to funding so the
germans say look we should use gas it's
a transitional uh power towards this net
zero the french say no no no nuclear is
better it hasn't got emissions the
germans say no nuclear is dangerous it
leaves behind radioactive waste so what
we've got then is on the face of it
something of a fudge where the european
union is said okay we'll we'll give the
thumbs up to both gas and
to nuclear trouble is that hasn't gone
down very well at all austria has said
that it is now considering legal action
remember the german government now has
the greens as partners and while olof
schultz the new chancellor is happy this
the greens definitely are not and all
this was thrown out on new year's eve
when no one was really looking
controversy yes
loads of it
adam thanks very much indeed
let's take a look announce on the day's
other climate news and investigators in
the u.s are searching for the cause of
the colorado wildfire that destroyed
nearly a thousand homes the fire broke
out unusually late in the year after
months of drought that included a dry
autumn and a winter with very little
snow
experts say the winter fire was rare but
similar events will become more common
due to climate change
and wild weather weather is wreaking
havoc across other parts of the u.s in
virginia hundreds of drivers were
trapped in their cars after a snowstorm
shut a major highway a 50-mile stretch
of interstate 95 was blocked after a
crash involving six tractor trailers
occurred on monday afternoon
more snow is expected to hit the region
later this week
prince charles has praised his sons for
their work in tackling the climate
crisis in an essay for u.s magazine
newsweek prince charles said he was
proud of prince william for launching
the earthshot prize and of prince harry
for pledging to make his charity
archwell net zero by 2030. the prince of
wales also used the essay to call on the
global fossil fuel industry to take
urgent action to address climate change
four beekeepers have been detained in
chile following a protest calling on the
government to help improve their
industry seven police officers were
stung as they tried to remove bee hives
placed by the protesters outside the
presidential palace in santiago
honey production in chile has been
affected by a long-term drought that
scientists partially blame on climate
change
china's capital beijing met state air
quality standards for the first time
last year according to the city's
environmental protection bureau efforts
to reduce pollution including reducing
the use of coal started in 2014
following a series of hazardous smog
buildups our china correspondent tom
cheshire has the latest from beijing
even in the four years i've been in
beijing the air quality has noticeably
improved there's a lot fewer smoggy days
and it's a world away from what happened
in 2014 we just had blankets of smog
over the city and that led to huge
public anger there was a documentary
that got a lot of attention and
authorities launched a campaign to try
and clean up the air quality they took a
number of measures they planted a lot of
trees they introduced emission standards
they tried to switch homes from burning
coal in the winter which is when there
was a lot of heavy pollution to burning
gas instead and all that does seem to
have led to a big improvement in the air
quality they also move factories from
inside the city to outside it to further
bring those pollutions down now there
are caveats to all of that the question
of whether beijing's air has been
improved at the expense of other cities
perhaps in mongolia the province a lot
of those factories moved to still has
very bad air quality even if beijing has
improved and second these sort of
standards uh the average we're talking
about is still nearly seven times higher
than what the who the world health
organization recommends as a safe limit
and to take an example today pretty good
day for pollution is still five times
more than what people are experiencing
in london so there is still a lot of
work to be done they certainly haven't
reached the goal but the trend has been
a good one it's made life a lot more
bearable for residents of beijing
zookeepers at london zoo have started
this year's stock take of more than 400
species they care for keepers will spend
around a week counting every animal from
arya the lioness to terry the sloth who
are new to the count this year
conservationists say it's important to
know how many of each species are in
captivity for potential breeding
programs we're getting straight to
discussing the climate issues of the day
now with the economist vicky price and
the climate columnist at the independent
donnica mccarthy so hello to both of you
happy new year to you both
so first of all earlier we heard how the
european commission is proposing that
both nuclear and natural or fossil gas
should be described as sustainable for
finance purposes nuclear power is carbon
free but expensive and leaves the huge
problem of toxic nuclear waste natural
gas is a polluting fossil fuel but less
so than coal
so do the eu's plans make sense well to
you first of all at donnacur well to
vicky first of all the eu says that gas
and nuclear are key to the transition to
cleaner power but some are calling it
green washing so let's take a look at
gas first of all are you happy to see it
classified as green
i am well we can't classify necessarily
as green if we are looking at the
details of how much co2 is actually
emitted by the use of gas but we can
certainly classify this considerably
greener than other fossil fuels and i
think that's the point that is being
made and of course so many countries
right now in europe depend on gas and as
they are getting out of nuclear like
germany is doing then there is really no
other option unless you fall back on
coal so gas is certainly a transition
um one to use over the next few years
and i think it's basically bound to the
inevitability that
this type of power generation will have
to be
used in europe for some time to come and
just to exclude it from uh use is just
not going to make any sense at all
donica we need a transition fuel a gas
will make a much less of an impact than
coal so can we go green without
well what it
not proposing is abolishing the use of
gas what they are proposed what we are
what the international energy agency
says is we cannot afford to build any
new
fossil fuel plants if we're going to hit
net zero 2050. so the idea that the
european union
labels
using methane-based gas as a green as a
green option is farcical it is
brainwashing and this is unacceptable
vicky should we talk about nuclear is as
well because france for example relies
on nuclear energy for more than 70
percent of its electricity it says the
eu can't reach its goal of carbon
neutrality by 2050 without it
it doesn't produce co2 so should it be
embraced as a sustainable option
i think what uh we need to look at is
quite the careful wording that the eu is
using which is
all nuclear is making it very clear
that what they are considering is
nuclear is acceptable if it doesn't um
have any serious problem in terms of
dealing with waste disposal at the end
and if it is actually built the new
nuclear plants in a certain way
that is also acceptable in terms of
climate change so they have a number of
stipulations there now of course there
are loads and loads of
old nuclear power stations around so you
could argue that perhaps we can make
better use of what we've got now and
then get rid of them perhaps
but in the sense that uh you know most
of them eventually uh if we get
renewable sources that can take over
from nuclear but if you look at what's
going on in france right now for example
given that they're so dependent on
nuclear at present even though they say
they want to reduce that and they are
expecting to reduce that quite
significantly as a percent of overall
energy use
nevertheless they are going to be
dependent on
not just the power stations they have
now but new ones as well
and that's the real issue because quite
a lot of the old ones uh are coming to
the end of their useful life so i'm
afraid we are going to have new nuclear
as well in the mix even though there are
still serious concerns about whether
because they are environmentally
friendly
well it's clear that they're not
environmentally friendly they've been
trying to find a solution to the waste
problem a toxic waste problem for 70
years without without coming up with one
but the other problem with in terms of
climate change it's very clear to build
a new nuclear power station from scratch
to it producing any electricity takes 20
years
that would mean that if we started today
to be the mid-2040s before any nuclear
power stations start helping us reduce
our carbon emissions which is 22 years
too late what we need to be doing is
concentrating on three things energy
efficiency investing in renewables and
investing in modern
storage technologies those are the three
investments that europe should be
looking at which the united kingdom
should be looking at
okay let's move on to our next topic
shall we now because it might be a
choice between heating and eating we
were warned today as energy bills look
set to rocket in the spring now some
energy suppliers and conservative mps
have said that one solution will be to
suspend vat and green taxes which are
currently levied on our bills so are
they right and donaka the figures are
quite startling aren't they the average
household energy bill could rise by
723 pounds per year that's one estimate
so
should the green taxes go in order to
help out consumers
yeah it's quite shocking and is going to
put a lot of people into fuel poverty
and what we have here is a failure to
invest in energy efficiency and
renewables for 20 years by the uk
government that's left us at the mercy
of the fossil fuel markets it's fossil
fuels which are exploding in cost not by
a factor of nine so what we should be
looking at is cutting green taxes we've
been cutting our investment in cutting
bills in the future cutting our noses by
our faces so what we should be looking
at is actually look
um if we cut example vat that means
you're giving a tax subsidy to the
middle classes and to the rich what we
should be doing is cutting is restoring
the universal credit cut that the
government did so poor people have the
money to pay the extra cost in um uh
fuel that it will be exploding over the
next few months
do you think that's the right solution
vicky and that green taxes should be
kept
i think what the government is to do is
intervene and intervene pretty fast
because there is indeed a crucial issue
as to whether people are going to be
able to afford the energy and that they
need to consume in their homes and
whether they'll be able to survive if
you like and this you know heating or
eating is actually a very important
issue for a very large number of people
and even you know if you look at the
middle classes which
of course you know tend to be a bit more
sheltered actually the increase is going
to be pretty substantial so uh what you
can do of course is keep those taxes
still there uh if you look at the
percentage that goes for what we call
government environmental and social
schemes it's about 13 percent and v80 is
about five percent is five percent
actually for household bills it's
slightly higher for well i said 20 for
um
business users except for those that
don't use an awful lot of energy when
it's five percent so they're not huge uh
and of course as prices are going up uh
they are you know substantial if you
look at the percentages but overall
what's really happening is that this
wholesale price for gas that's going up
very significantly has gone up but the
question is how long will that last i
think there is a short-term issue to
medium-term issue that the government
needs to meet which is basically
assisting energy companies to keep those
uh increases that have to come at some
point down as much as possible and
looking at the price cap as well the way
it goes up in april so we don't get
those very substantial increases what
we've seen in various other countries is
that they have intervened they have done
something about vat they have done
something about some of those social
payments so actually i think government
needs to intervene very very
significantly
do you come in yeah the other the other
point is larger than green taxes is the
standing charges the standing charges
around 200 pounds on a gas electricity
bill is a tax on the poor why should a
poor pensioner living in a small flat
one room flat by ourselves pay the same
amount in standing charge as a massive
as a massive palace for a billionaire
but this they should be strapped and
that should be transferred to the to the
um bills themselves so that poor people
are not actually hammered by it so i'm
suggesting two things for poor people
restore the environmental credit cut and
actually abolish the standing charges so
poor people are not hammered by their
energy bills or the coming months
okay well done mccarthy and uh vicky
price i suspect this is something we
will return to in future weeks and
months but for the moment thanks both
very much indeed
thank you
now tomorrow show i'm going to be joined
by the chief executive of the climate
group helen clarkson and climate
scientist dr ella gilbert so do join me
for that meanwhile thanks for watching
and i'll see you next time
[Music]